moscou pensé faire tomber kiev
rapidement mais un mois après le
lancement de l'offensive russe la
capitale résiste toujours
les russes avait prévu d'être à kiev il
ya trois semaines déjà mais les
ukrainiens ont détruit les plans des
jeux
et ont montré qu'ils ont de bonnes
tactiques et qu'ils défendront la ville
pour l'instant les troupes russes sont
tenus à distance du centre ville mais
des bombardements continuent de faire
des victimes et de détruire des
bâtiments
c'est en périphérie que tout se joue au
nord-ouest la zone dire pin était ce
mercredi le théâtre d'intenses combats
mais les troupes russes font face à une
forte résistance des ukrainiens elles
ont aussi été stoppée autour des
localités de boudhha et au sto mail plus
loin toujours à l'ouest hama car il
résume craignant même contre-attaqué et
affirment avoir repris du terrain à 75
kilomètres du centre de kiev
c'est à l'est que se concentre le gros
des combats même si là aussi les
ukrainiens tienne board
nous sommes sous un bombardement
constant
artillerie lourde tanks canons utilise
le calibre 120 ils bombardent les civils
aussi
alors pour se protéger ces soldats
creusent des tranchées à l'aide de
pelles
sépare le nord que les russes
maintiennent la pression mais le verrou
clé de brovary résiste toujours un peu
plus au sud à boryspil le maire a
conseillé à ses habitants de quitter les
lieux
selon le pentagone à l'est de kiev
l'armée russe aurait reculé de plus de
30 km en 24 heures